beat up if you been with a comeback the
drop in commodity says his market filled
taken hits did you avoid it no no we
were on the wrong side of a first to the
first leg of it and that sort of
September period and certainly was
painful I mean I think what we missed
and what some other people missed was
that it's really a supply story not a
demand story I actually think the demand
for commodities is relatively okay but
there's just there's just been this
massive oversupply and so in so many
areas which which i think is an outcome
of central banking policy right now wait
so if but if we're talking about
oversupply of commodities so that the
problem is not China it's Australia well
the problem problem is that commodity
producers have gone down a business plan
of producing as much as they can no
matter what the no matter what the end
prices and you know you had you know
enough exploration and you you found
enough deposits of low-cost commodities
both in iron ore and in energy in
particular that you know the margin
notes you have this short period where
the marginal profitability was enormous
but now you're just at this this sort of
battle to the death where the suppliers
are willing to sell you know one dollar
above their marginal costs we had six or
seven central banks cut rates last week
I mean this really does look like
full-fledged currency wars competitive
devaluation whatever you want to call it
why aren't we seeing a bigger pop and
gold well you are if you look outside of
US dollars golden euros is off about
thirty percent over the last 12 months
is up about twenty-five percent in
canadian dollars it's up twenty percent
plus in most international currencies
you know that's a pretty good pop you
know in US dollars the dollar is v if
you like for beneficiary of everything
which is happening on on the other side
in US dollars gold is up mid-single
digits over that period of time but
that's a real pop you just have to look
at the right currency to see it but
everybody else who comes to our show to
talk about commodities talks about china
and i find it interesting that you're
not talking about china for you you
don't see a drawback you don't see a
fall fall off and demand there is the
problem you know i think there's been a
lack of growth in China there hasn't
been a reduction of Chinese imports of
most of most key commodities I think
there has been a financial deleveraging
in China and i do think to the extent
people were using physical commodities
as collateral for lending i think that's
been part of what happened in the back
end of back end of 2014 but
china hasn't stopped buying iron ore
it's not bang on or at a place which
suited bhp and Rio and everybody else
right Oh on a micro economic basis how
easy is it for the miners to clear that
oversupply they got into it over
quarters in years do you have an
optimism that they can clear it out in a
matter of quarters no cuz nobody's
talking in the right way everybody's
assuring the shareholder base that
they're still marginally profitable
where they are you know I would far far
about it but ever hear people say look
we're just not going to dig the stuff
out of the ground right now but I don't
think anybody has the ability to do it
and particular when you look at the
amount of fixed income which has been
issued in this face Olivia the Baker
Hughes transaction earlier this year
really goes to what we may see which is
real combinations yeah we're expecting
that this is going to precipitate sort
of a massive flurry of consolidation of
M&A in the energy sector and then we are
also watching out for exxon earnings at
8am I have a chart actually that shows a
incredible drop from baker hughes in the
rig's look at the right hand side of
that job yeah I mean that is really
stunning sure let's move it count yeah
it's real okay due to my point earlier
Olivia that's brilliant can we can that
speed up connect go faster than the
market thinks to clear out the supply
well yes it can but as rigs and rigs I
mean a from what I'm told about twenty
percent of the wigs in this country
produce eighty percent of the V of the
oil so you can't simply look at the vid
can to see but i think you have started
the process whereby supply starts to
come under attack but it's a longer it's
a long post i smell long and nasty
cycling long and nastya